stunning views of the Aegean Sea and
white houses carved into cliffs 300
meters above the island archipelago of
Santorini is among Greece's most popular
tourist destinations many of the
traditional houses in the Socratic style
are no hotels and holiday apartments
petrol Dupin eyota restored many of the
houses destroyed in an earthquake almost
60 years ago preserving the original
style this round roofs were due to the
local material there are no forest in
Santorini so they used the material the
stones and the stones here are not flat
around so they were to build the visa
they were making around the former in
ancient times Santorini was a single
cone shaped volcanic island about 3,600
years ago a massive eruption created the
current curved archipelago today a cable
car connects Farah to the old port from
here excursion boats offer a very
special volcano tour first stop is Nia
Kamini a small uninhabited island of
volcanic origin whose name means newly
burnt it's erupted sporadically over the
centuries smoke and sulfur fumes rise
from the still-active 120 meter high
crater the eyelids peek
today we're not erupt we have the
geological Institute which text activity
of the volcano so you're completely safe
if there is a chance of an eruption will
work months before even a year before
next up is the neighboring Island
oppalia kamini which means old burnt
this one is no longer active but it has
a bay with a hot spring that makes
swimming possible even when air
temperatures are cool
it was good it was cold but a little bit
warmer when she got over there it was
good refreshing it was only warming
patches so it was only little bits were
but you get used to it back to the main
island as well as entertaining tourists
it's volcanic heritage also gives local
wines a unique taste although it rarely
rains the vines thrive because of the
high absorption rate of the volcanic
surface Santorini wines enjoy an
excellent reputation and are one of the
archipelago's biggest exports the
tomatoes alber genes and beans grown
here also tastes wonderful many
restaurants in the southeastern part of
the island served both locally sourced
vegetables and wine head chef Anastasio
spa haridas works wonders with the local
products at his seaside restaurant on
perry Volos beach as his patrons confirm
the food is just amazing because it has
a mixture a tradition of Greek of
Santorini and contemporary modern modern
twist to it everything he makes is
really excellent you know always
surprising you delicious food fine wine
and the spectacular landscape attract a
very special type of tourists couples
who come to say I do some 2,000 weddings
take place every season on Santorini and
lela Constantine ooh has been offering a
complete nuptial package for the past 15
years last year's Chinese heard about it
they love it and so this is a new market
that was added into the Western market
that was coming for a wedding an ideal
destination for the romantically
inclined the view west from the town of
oil 200 meters above the sea entices
tourists every evening gathered to catch
the legendary sunsets enjoyed by the
young and old alike